meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
guten tag die steigenden energiepreise
sind eine große belastung für sehr viele
bürgerinnen und bürger die
bundesregierung ist sich einig dass den
gaskunden keine zusätzlichen belastungen
entstehen sollen aus der obligatorischen
erhebung der mehrwertsteuer auf die gass
umlagen dies betrifft insbesondere die
in bekannte gasbeschaffung sum lage es
gilt aber auch für weitere aufschläge
wie die bilanzierungs umlage die wird
vom trading up europe jedes jahr
festgelegt und für 2022 23 in diesen
minuten verkündet
die bundesregierung hat deshalb heute
entschieden die mehrwertsteuer auf
gasverbrauch zeitlich befristet auf 7
prozent abzusenken der ermäßigte
mehrwertsteuersatz wird so lange gelten
wie die gast beschaffungs umlage erhoben
werden wird also bis zum 31 märz 2000 24
mit diesem schritt entlasten wir die
gaskunden insgesamt deutlich stärker als
die mehrbelastung die durch die umlagen
entsteht wir erwarten von den
unternehmen dass sie diese senkung eins
zu eins an die verbrauchern verbraucher
weitergeben das werden wir auch sehr
klar kommunizieren klar ist dies ist ein
weiterer schritt zur entlastung
ich habe gesagt you'll never walk alone
in den nächsten wochen werden wir ein
drittes entlastungs paket schnüren um
den großen druck der auf vielen
bürgerinnen und bürgern aber auch
unternehmen lastet abzumildern wie das
paket genau aussieht besprechen wir
vertrauensvoll in der regierung die
gerechtigkeitsfrage ist entscheidend
damit das land in dieser krise zusammen
bleibt vielen dank
[Musik]